what up space fam goes in here from
anime opera and with the crazy new
developments in the one piece story
especially in terms of bounties i
thought it was a great time to do an
updated list of the most wanted pirates
of all time if you do enjoy one piece
videos like this one channel parking
within and smash that like button
remember smashing his pirating energy
and passing is scared of deutsche energy
so choose wisely if you haven't joined
the nakama by subscribing and hitting
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications so you don't miss future
one-piece videos and updates now i want
to thank dnf duel for sponsoring this
video all of us here love anime waifus
epic battles and great stories and dnf
duel offers all that and more one of the
most popular and widely played rpgs
dungeon fighters now back as a 2.5 d
action fighting game for ps4 ps5 and pc
it's packed with lore and great
character designs my personal favorite
being dragon knight not only is she
gorgeous i've also always loved dragons
so being able to use one as a weapon in
a fight is amazing and the dragon's so
cute as well plus dragon knight can fly
which is just so cool the game is so
easy to pick up that you can get started
right away i just jumped into the story
mode and figured it out as i went while
making quick work of my opponents the
game's fun funky and has badass
beautiful and adorable characters to
choose from i'm loving it dnf duel is
available on ps4 ps5 and pc now via
steam check it out right now by using
the link in my description i'll see you
there and now without further ado let's
jump into it spoilers and all so as you
guys know bounties aren't
straightforward they don't just
represent the strength of someone they
can represent the crew's threat level
their threat level to the world
government and established world order
and sometimes it may even be kept
smaller than it should be so as not to
give too much attention to an especially
dangerous pirate as we are about to see
so just keep all that in mind bounties
are hype but they are ultimately just a
weapon that the world government has at
their disposal and in the end they use
it in any way that will best serve their
own ends so at number 10 we start off
strong with luffy's old bounty of 1.5
billion berries this was actually
luffy's sixth bounty and happened after
he was recognized as sabo's further
tying him to the revolutionaries the
most dangerous organization to the world
government and after the events of whole
cake island and his defeat of yonko
commander charlotte cracker whose bounty
was 860 million and big mom's strongest
commander charlotte kanakuri whose
bounty was 1.057 billion with this
bounty luffy also gained the title the
fifth emperor thanks to the legend the
big news morgans as the title suggests
this bounty catapulted luffy above all
yonko commanders and only the yonko were
left for him to pass to be fair luffy
was catapulted ahead of all yonko
commanders with known bounties
specifically but we still don't know
some bounties like ben beckman's which
could potentially be quite high number
nine is none other than yonko blackbeard
at
2.2476 billion berries this is probably
one of the most hyped top 10 lists ever
when number 10 and 9 are luffy and yonko
blackbeard but it's true unless
blackbeard's bounty has changed off
screen which is definitely possible as
we'll discuss later his current bounty
is less than luffy's blackbeard was
previously a member of the whitebeard
pirate then he became a warlord he
defeated ace one of whitebeard's
strongest commanders in battle he went
on to recruit multiple level 6 prisoners
at impel down as sengoku described it he
took the strongest of the world's most
dangerous prisoners sengoku says even
one level 6 prisoner can cause
unimaginable chaos simply by
infiltrating a nation so you can imagine
that multiple working together under the
master planner blackbeard is much more
concerning of course he also
participated in the summit war at
marineford and you can even say he was
the biggest winner in it not only did he
get strong crew members he also killed
yonko whitebeard the strongest man in
the world who to be fair was very
injured and blackbeard sort of just
swooped in after the heavy lifting was
done but still it's a very legend
building detail that people can say
about blackbeard he then stole the
guragura no a fruit that is said to be
able to destroy the world and is
considered to be the strongest paramecia
fruit and became the first character we
know of to wield two devil fruits even
though that's supposed to be impossible
finally he to use robin's own word
obliterated marco and the remnants of
the whitebeard pirates during the
payback war and in doing so solidified
his position as the newest yonko thus
it's no surprise he received such a high
bounty next for number eight number
seven and number six we have a three-way
tie surprisingly and now we really start
to break from tradition in regards to
how bounty levels are determined just
recently it's been revealed that monkey
d luffy eustis kid and trafalgar d water
law all received a three billion barry
bounty i don't want to take anything
away from kid and law they killed it
this arc they've been amazing together
they beat a yonko namely big mom who had
a bounty of over 4 billion so i'm
totally cool with their combined bounty
being higher than big mom's bounty but
the problem is luffy got the same bounty
even though he took down kaido alone for
all intents and purposes despite some
other characters hurting kaido a bit
before their match plus there's the fact
that luffy just awakened the most
ridiculous power in the world that the
world government arguably fears the most
these bounties only make sense if a they
don't consider the details of the
battles just the fact that these three
supernova be too yonko or b if the world
government wants to avoid putting any
extra spotlight on luffy then absolutely
necessary the latter is probably the
case as we saw them freak out over
luffy's gear 5 aka awakened sun god nika
form being featured on his wanted poster
along with the d initial in his name
they want to spin the story like these
three roughly equal supernova beat these
two yonko and that's that this way they
hope to limit the attention on luffy the
joy boy and warrior of liberation of the
new era who if legend is correct is the
biggest threat to the world government
because he is destined to free all those
under the government's control thus in
my view luffy after beating the
strongest creature in the world and
awakening the most ridiculous power that
hasn't been seen in 800 years deserves
the highest bounty we've seen to date
but because it would actually be bad for
the government to put the spotlight on
the worry of liberation they purposely
used the wanted poster to hide the truth
as much as they could showing that in
the end the wanted posters are but tools
for the government to use for their own
benefit and not objective or scientific
measurements of threat level or strength
number five is yonko shanks at
4.0489 billion berries and believe it or
not now our red-haired boy has the
highest known active bounty in the
series this serves the government well
because they know shanks is not the one
to cause unnecessary trouble and the
five elders are even willing to secretly
meet with him without trying to capture
him showing that they are not too
worried about him obviously in their
view luffy is a bigger threat but they
still gave luffy a lower bounty for
tactical reasons number four and number
three are big mom at 4.388 billion and
kaido at
4.6111 billion both of their bounties
have become inactive in light of their
recent defeats by the three supernova
kid law and luffy it's funny to look at
how the world government uses bounties
to help manipulate public perception in
light of recent events the public might
assume the two most dangerous living
yonko with the highest known bounties
have been defeated and now the
government's job must be easier because
instead of taking down the strongest
creature in the world and his legendary
yonko partner they only gotta take down
three upstarts who are weaker
individually than either of the yonko in
reality the situation is much worse
though as we know since in kaido's case
he was more or less close with the world
government close enough to allow cp-0
agents to chill in his territory however
luffy who physically beat the strongest
creature in the world cannot be
controlled and will continue to seek
liberation for others which will require
eventually the downfall of the world
government and he won't compromise his
ideals so even though we know kaido was
less of a threat to the world government
they don't let luffy pass kaido's bounty
or even big mom's bounty number two is
whitebeard at 5.046 billion this one is
obviously also inactive since whitebeard
is dead after all however when he lived
he not only possessed the power to
destroy the world via the guragura no me
he was also viewed as the strongest man
in the world and the man closest to one
piece he fought on equal terms with his
rival pirate king gold d roger and as a
younger man he arguably could have
become the next pirate king and found
the one piece but he wasn't interested
because he prioritized his crew aka his
family he was uninterested in the one
piece and in taking down the world
government until they wanted to execute
his family and so it was safe for the
world government to let him keep the
highest active bounty while he lived
furthermore when he died a marine ford
that again helped the government's
public image in the sense that they
could look back and say they helped take
down the biggest threat in the world and
thus the world is now a safer place and
even the strongest man in the world
wasn't strong enough to beat the world
government lastly number one is the
great pirate gold d roger the former
pirate king as with luffy the government
wanted to erase the d from his name and
in his case succeeded by changing his
name to gold roger on the wanted poster
this is a little clue to us that luffy
has reached a similar status in the eyes
of the world government and i of course
think he's more dangerous as i've
explained because roger didn't have the
sun god nika fruit furthermore as roger
mentioned before he knew he was too
early so he wasn't planning to take down
the world government in fact we were
told he helped the world government and
celestial dragons at god valley when he
worked together with the hero of the
marines garp to take down the rock's
pirates then he handed himself over to
the world government when he was sick
and so the world government looked
strong because they got to publicly
execute him the man with the highest
bounty ever as far as we know from the
government's perspective they might
purposely never want to give any other
enemy a higher bounty because as things
stand they can always publicly maintain
the image that if they could beat and
execute the pirate king goldie roger
then no one should think that a pirate
with a lower bounty can take them down
in this way the government maintains the
appearance of strength even though
behind the scenes the situation is way
different and way worse for them and so
these last bounty reveals have
completely changed the game and the way
we view bounties now dragon might in
fact have a lower bounty than he
deserves even if he's the world's worst
criminal because the government doesn't
want to give him too much attention or
hype that being said i should clarify
that i've discussed known bounties in
this video and it's quite likely that
future revealed bounties will change the
makeup of this list for instance dragon
might break into the top 10. blackbeard
might have a new bounty which would make
sense or else to non-yanko namely kit
and law would have higher bounties than
him the myth the man the legend buggy d
clown who became a new yonko along with
luffy also might have a bounty now that
gets him into this top 10 list so i may
need to do an updated version sooner
rather than later but for now just let
me know your top picks for who will
break into this list will rox d zebek
will ben beckman will zorro let me know
your thoughts in the comments smash that
like button if you enjoyed this video be
a smashing pirate king rather than a
passing orochi if you have enjoyed the
nakama by subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next video to drop feel
free to check out my huge and growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on all the admirals yonko warlords and
much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys